Jim Parsons and husband Todd Spiewak  enjoy a romantic Italian getaway it was  really fun the Big Bang Theory star tied  the knot with his longtime love at the  Rainbow Room in NYC last week and now  the two are enjoying married life  honeymooning in Capri Italy the 44 year  old actor and his hubby looked stylish  while boating Jim rocked a casual  cream-colored sweater and salmon pink  shorts for the outing pairing the look  with a white fedora and shades  Todd appeared dapper in a navy blue and  white striped polo with khaki pants and  blue loafers the newlyweds were later  seen smiling and cheersing while  enjoying a romantic dinner it was really  special  you